over the last couple months I've gotten
a number of what I would call
educational or pedagogical questions
some of them have to do with the nature
of education today primarily in America
but also you know thinking about the
world and quite a few of them have to do
with how one ought to study the
discipline that I focus on most which is
philosophy so now that I have a full
complement to 10 i can I can shoot one
of these ten shorts videos and address
some of these questions again if you're
interested in this sort of thing keep
the questions coming in on the video
page that I set up specifically for that
and as soon as I get enough of them in a
given category I will compile some
answers to them
so this is a great starting open-ended
big picture question x marks mitt do you
think that the current educational
structures and objectives are sufficient
and a simple answer is no but the answer
requires a lot more explanation than
that and i'm just going to like hit some
very quick bullet points here i think
this is something I should shoot a lot
more video about and perhaps engaged in
some doctors to other philosophy forums
about this objectives what is the goal
of Education is it to produce citizens
and consumers and you know workers who
can get things done in the ways that
they're supposed to is a primarily
vocational or kind of aspirational or is
it going to be something that we do in
fact pedal a lot as you know the key to
success the key to a better life the
thing that has the best return on
investment for young minds put yourself
in debt to get that or is it an industry
like many other industries these are the
sort of questions we ought to be looking
at and notice that none of them have
actually hit on what some of the real
objectives of education the ones that
are harder to quantify but can actually
be be dealt with in qualitative ways
that are quite rigorous we haven't
discussed what the real purpose is of
Education are what you have to do with
the development of the human person and
the continuation of human culture and
being ready to take on the problems and
challenges that we're going to face and
not in some vague you know sort of
aspirational sense but actually being
equipped for that are the current
educational structures fostering that
for the most part know if you want to
become educated I think that this is the
time where you actually have to do a lot
of work on your own and a lot of
thinking about your own development and
what resources you're going to use and
what communities you're going to align
yourself with and what models you're
going to take
this is a question by one of my frequent
interlocutor zero she flies and he is
wondering specifically about how many
colleges and universities offer
interdisciplinary courses that explore
the interplay of philosophy science
religion and history and the answer is
not enough and much of what they are
offering is not particularly good or
useful I think it requires you know to
do something like that requires that you
actually understand both of the fields
that you're you're trying to work with
you might say the same thing about
philosophy of language or if we want to
talk about economy or if we want to talk
about mathematics or computer modeling
or all these other sort of things when
there's interpret interdisciplinary work
being carried out it requires that you
really speak two languages that you you
have you know achieved at least
intermediate status in both fields and i
think that there's a lot of dabbling
that goes on which partly leads to the
disrespect in which interdisciplinary
studies gets gets placed especially by
the the practitioners of the fields that
are seen as being more rigorous in
philosophy this is a real problem I
think that that philosophers quite often
do philosophy of XYZ but don't know an
awful lot about that and I think that
one of the prime reasons for that is the
models of what counts is philosophy that
have been predominant whether analytic
or continental they both I think do more
damage to the the you know Student
Information history of philosophy
provides better grounding for that I
think but not a not an adequate
grounding there's there's more that has
to be done there so a lot more that
could be said about this
so another sort of follow-up question by
Mark Smith should education at a
post-secondary level be primarily about
vocational training or should there be
an element of personal cultivation that
strives for more than that it's framed
as an either/or I think that actually
both of these are very important but I
think both of them need to be thought
out in rather different ways so
vocational training I'm I have nothing
against vocational training I actually
think that we have too many students
going into colleges and universities and
I think that we don't have enough people
going into trade schools which are you
know real folk tech stuff I think that
there's a lot of students would be quite
quite happy who aren't happy going into
college and taking the tracks that are
available to them there and there's tons
of jobs available to those who actually
go and and learn some sort of trade
industry leaders are actually worried
that we might not have enough young
people in the trades to maintain vital
infrastructure in the coming generations
so I have nothing against voc-tech
personal cultivation that's not
incompatible with vocational training as
a matter of fact if you're doing
vocational training right it shouldn't
just be vocational training you should
be teaching somebody how to be a
practitioner within their field and to
see that there's other things outside of
their discipline or their trade or their
skill that impinge upon it you know what
we would call say you know an
Aristotelian framework practical wisdom
you know I see this when I when I come
in and do guest lectures at the Culinary
Institute of America and talked to
budding chefs about what Aristotle can
teach them about how to be I'd be a chef
personal cultivation is more than just
learning who you are or you know things
like that learning what your values are
exploring those it should connect you to
the to the rest of culture at least
that's my view on it
so here's a question by Cody sitting can
you recommend any textbooks on critical
thinking skills not I haven't carried
out any exhaustive review of critical
thinking textbooks for several years and
I have never found a textbook that made
me sit up and take notice and say wow
this is really spectacular as a matter
of fact I may write my own like because
I tend to be dissatisfied with what I
what I see now that said you don't
expect a text book to be something great
because it's a textbook nobody should
ever take a college textbook as being
the last word or an adequate exhaustive
treatment of of anything if you actually
want to study something you go to you
know primary sources and you go to other
expert practitioners who deal with that
sort of stuff so what I want to see in a
critical thinking textbook and this
might give you some idea of what to look
for is a few negative things than a few
positive things I don't want to see any
overt bias on the part of the author I
tend to see more critical thinking
textbooks that are biased towards the
left because academics tend to be kind
of leftist then to the right and I don't
like that I think that's bad for
students they already get enough you
know biased stuff you know coming at
them from everywhere from everybody else
that's probably enough for the negative
what should it include okay so it should
be discussions of deductive and
inductive reasoning there should be
discussions and arguments how to analyze
them how to evaluate them there should
be a lot of you might say obstacle
courses and training grounds for being
able to recognize bad arguments what we
call the fallacies being able to diagram
and break down arguments how to make
arguments of your own how to see when to
move from one kind of argument to
another kind of argument stuff about
information sources is often very
important to include there and that's
tougher to do so those are the sort of
things that I like to see in a critical
thinking textbook
so another question by Cody sitting he
has an interest in formal and informal
logic and wants to know are these the
same as critical thinking skills or is
the study of logic meant to be
understood in conjunction with the art
of critical thinking and it's the latter
if we talk about formal logic in
particular formal logic is not the same
thing whether we think of it in terms of
a discipline like what actually gets
taught what gets studied or if we think
of it in terms of what you're doing it's
not the same thing as critical thinking
critical thinking is broader and it can
use formal logic as a tool to either
construct or to break down or to
evaluate arguments but formal logic does
not adequately capture the ways in which
we human beings actually do reason with
each other what can be understood as not
only valid or sound but persuasive and
what we ought to what a rational being
ought to be willing to accept at least
for the time being informal logic and
critical thinking those often tend to
get kind of blurred together because you
know nobody's quite sure exactly what
informal logic means and I'm sure
there's gonna be somebody commenting
giving some textbook definition but I'm
saying across the discipline there is
not a complete consensus on what counts
as informal logic there isn't done
critical thinking either if you actually
look there's several different models of
what counts is critical thinking some of
the more narrow some of them much more
expansive it's one of those terms that
lots of people throw around because it
sounds cool but many of them have no
idea what it means I would say that you
know informal logic critical thinking
these are actually more focused on the
kinds of arguments that human beings
actually do make with each other logic
formal logic is actually much more like
mathematics and actually it is closely
connected
that
this is a question about studying
philosophy in general by andy hall c and
he's asking if i recommend a linear
progression from ancient to modern or a
more scattered approach to reading
philosophical writings so i'm assuming
that this is for somebody who is
deciding what classes to take if they're
in a college or university or they're
sort of studying these things on their
own I do in fact recommend a fairly
linear progression I don't say that you
have to read every single person all the
way along the way because obviously some
are more important and influential than
others or they have some you know really
brilliant thoughts that you don't want
to miss out on so yeah I do recommend
the linear progression rather than a
scattershot thing in part because you
know as we move through the ancient all
the way into the later modern not eat
not just the early modern but the later
modern these people are incorporating
each other's thoughts they're reacting
to them they've studied each other it
helps you to understand you know say for
example for example you know to actually
know something about ancient and
medieval philosophy does help you with
somebody like Descartes who is trying to
break from those traditions so yeah I do
recommend that I think it's really
important to that you don't leave out
medieval you know you talk about ancient
and then modern and too many people skip
over the medieval and you know we should
also think about modern as being early
modern and and late modern maybe with
can't or Hume as being the nice dividing
point for that that's probably enough to
be said about that
so this is a question about changing
from one field to another in one way of
thinking about things to another or
perhaps others by David few salir he's
considering getting a PhD in philosophy
and he says what would be your advice as
someone who has a BS in physics and is
interested in switching to philosophy
and he adds it's been eight years since
he graduated so a point the first thing
I would say is don't expect philosophy
to be like physics but that probably
goes without saying but this is
something that a lot of people you know
fall into they think that because there
are fields in which there there is quite
a you know quite a lot of convergence
not complete you know there have been
some very interesting controversies and
physics over the years they are
philosophy ought to be like that or it's
no good you know and there are even
certain philosophers like say Immanuel
Kant who will give you that idea you
know the whole history before me was all
of errors and now I'm going to finally
get it right if you want to get
something out of your experience of
studying as a graduate student in
philosophy you should expect to study a
lot of people with whom you will
disagree that may continue to disagree
even after you studied them and that's
okay the key question is what do you
disagree on and if you want to have a
different position than there is how is
your position more adequate to
experience to the fruits of reflection
to you know say the history of the
discussion of the topic then there is is
so you want you know it requires a
different sort of attitude towards
towards things I would say you know
here's a plug study the history of
philosophy that's where the greatest
riches are I mean you can always do
analytic philosophy or continental
philosophy you know or some you know
tiny narrow sub-discipline later on what
you really want to do is get a good
grounding
and what human culture this very
important long-standing tradition has to
offer you
so here's a question by Dimitri Andre of
and it might sound a little off the wall
but actually there's there's something
to this he asked do you think that one
needs to listen and each his favorite
music in order to understand his
philosophy and no you don't actually
need to I don't think it could hurt but
doing that may not actually help you I
mean I you know I tried listening to
vogner and I'm sure as hell I don't get
the same but each it was getting out of
it and it did kind of helped me see you
know put a few things into 2 into place
as far as like the birth of tragedy and
you know the antique vogner diatribes
later on but no I don't think you need
to listen to bogna or barely odor or any
of these people in order to make sense
out of what he's saying because the the
thought you know speaks for itself but
there's a larger question here to what
degree do we need to try to engage try
to not necessarily immerse ourselves in
but to at least take on some of the
things that these particular thinkers
found attractive found compelling found
repulsive in order to adequately or more
adequate adequately understand them I'm
kind of hip to that because I found that
you know actually doing the Liturgy of
the hours help me understand handsome a
bit better there are some things where
where it does help to do that sort of
thing would you need to hang around in
Parisian cafes to understand sorry I
don't think so could it help to be kind
of a you know a bastard in your personal
life probably would there's a lot of
things like that so the question is how
central are these to developing an
understanding of the thinker
marksman ask a question about psychology
and my my views about that what is your
view on the various schools of
psychology that have arisen over the
last 150 years or so what do you see is
especially relevant in providing
significant insight into humanity and he
says he's particularly interested in my
view and jungian psychology and that's
pretty easily summed up I'm not
interested in it very much what of it
that I studied did not particularly
impress me i really liked Young's take
on other people like frightened toddler
but I I don't buy the Jungian sort of
approach or paradigm and I could say the
same thing about ryky and psychology and
and some of the other stuff I also you
know it would say that when it comes to
there's a lot of different feet you know
a lot of movements a lot of figures in
psychology over the last 150 years some
of them I just find so incredibly off
base that it you know it's just sort of
a sign of how damaged people can be how
needy they can be 44 simple answers that
anybody could take say behavior ism you
know Skinner's type seriously but a lot
of people do I tend to focus on what
provides me with the sort of background
that I have in humanities and culture
with some some useful tools that seem to
actually fit in well with the sort of
things that I interested in studying
likes a virtue ethics there I'm more
attracted to the the Freudian line
especially through you know people like
Jacques Lacan and Hans cohort you know
these psychoanalysts I also you know I
find cognitive behavior therapy kind of
interesting provided it doesn't go too
far into the you shouldn't be doing
judgments and stuff like that which I
find to be nonsense but you know you
notice cognitive behavior therapy
founded in stoicism all right so you can
understand why I would find that sort of
thing interesting if not necessarily
compelling
this is a great question to close with
by James bartos and I'm already smiling
some thinking of look this and and how I
react and he asks how do you respond
when people tell you an outlandish
philosophical theory and the question
was was not just about philosophy but
also about theology and there's
something about the field of philosophy
you do get a lotta whacked-out really
out there kind of kind of theories
getting presented to you particular if
you seem like you know a fairly nice guy
and receptive just shows they don't
really know me that well um I do get
quite a few people coming up to me who
are quite frankly cranks some of them
even describe themselves as that and my
attitude has changed over the years I
used to be real hothead and I would get
into arguments with people because my
feeling was why are you wasting my time
with this crap if you know I i I've
tended to shift more to why why do you
find this this sort of thing interesting
and not not engaging in it and you know
sometimes things will come to light that
I couldn't have expected or hoped for
that actually turned out to have some
sort of value or basis to them in these
conversations so I would I guess you can
say that my attitude or my response when
people do this sort of thing is face to
face pretty it's not receptive but
respectful on the interwebs it's a
somewhat different matter because I get
people like commenting on videos and
they're like coming out of some weird
thing you know and I have less patience
for that in part because I have less
time you know if I'm actually meeting
people face-to-face that time has been
set aside if I'm supposed to respond to
somebody who doesn't even share the
basic
positions about what we're talking about
I don't often feel like I have time for
that and I can get pretty impatient with
with some people sometimes I just you
know delete their comments you know
because I don't feel like dealing with
them quite frankly